all right
clover clover where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
um i grew up in bethlehem florida
right outside of orlando florida and
how was your childhood you had both your
parents when you were young
no i was um i had what
they told me that they adopted me
these this married couple
that uh they they told everyone that
that that we knew the story about them
calling
like charities catholic charities
calling in the middle of the night
and saying that they had a girl for
adoption
and they said they had to drive up to
mobile alabama
where i was adopted through a car window
at a monastery because they said that um
they might recognize someone in the
monastery
so they couldn't go inside is what they
said
but i um at what age was this
i was a baby
so you don't remember it that uh no i
just remember them
telling the story so these
the parents that raised you
they you're saying it wasn't exactly
a legal adoption no it wasn't they they
took me
i was trained as a baby and they took me
and they they they grabbed me through
the car window and
drove back to florida with me
when i was a young child how was your
childhood with this santa
i don't remember much because i was
drugged
a lot um i would sleep sometimes for
60 hours you know for days and days and
nobody
nobody woke me up or questioned it um
a lot of times i would go with these
couples
they were very wealthy couples that
would come
um and pick me up one couple
my whole life you know as i was
growing up when i was six eight years
old 11 years old they would come and
and get me and they had a really nice
house
and the woman would hang out with me a
lot but i never talked
to the man they offered
to send me to school to send me to a
school
not to live at their house but to live
at the school a girls school and
they offered to send me to college and
the woman
who had taken me refused
and wouldn't let me see them anymore i
never saw them again
i remember when i was six years old one
night
in the middle of the night a couple came
and we lived like in a very rural area
there was it was dark in the streets
and um i remember
marilyn that was her name the lady she
got me up
in the middle of the night and um
she's and her husband asked where i was
going
and she said well she's going to go to
disney world with some friends of mine
and their daughter
and um he said oh that's nice you know
so i went out to the car and i got in
the car and there was a little boy
not a little girl in the car
and he was screaming and crying and i
i was terrified i didn't know what
happened to him he was my age
and i i sunk down six
i sunk down into the seat you know
behind the
behind the driver's seat and where you
put your feet
i sunk down there i was really scared
but i remember
that she she had drugged me again
because i didn't
wake up until the lady had me in her
arms
and she put me in a in a hotel room
where there was two big king-sized beds
but there was no one else in the room
and she she tucked me in and then
i remember that i woke up again in their
car about five minutes from my house
and i said to them i remember saying to
them
where's him and
he said oh well you know he didn't even
come with us
what about disney world i said it and
they said oh well you slept through
the whole thing that's what they told me
but i knew at that point you know
something's up there's no
you know we didn't go to disney world
but i
i to this day i i wonder what happened
to that little boy and why he didn't
come back with us you know
so what other what kind of stuff was
going on with this family you think
um well the daddy didn't talk much i had
a
foster sister and
they registered her for adoption but
she's the only one that got registered
for adoption
i ended up getting her name
and she um she chopped off her own arm
to here she had three fingers
and they that were left that she hadn't
destroyed
she cut off her own fingers yes she did
she cut off her own arm and her own
fingers at like three years old
and that's i think that's why they
adopted me because
she was really smart she knew
that they were trafficking her and she
mutilated her own body
so that they would stop and that she
wouldn't be
marketable you know i did i didn't know
most the whole time that that i was
being
trafficked but how could i i was just a
baby i was just a kid
i was drugged you know when i
when i went to this outpatient to find
out why i couldn't stop
doing drugs you know they hypnotized me
and they said well you know over the
next month things will start coming out
memories that you you you won't
you will have suppressed or will are
going to come out
and sure enough they did and it was
all about being sexually trafficked
as a child what's wild is i grew up i
was a cocktail waitress
and i was drugged again as a cocktail
waitress in my 20s
and i woke up
in a room full of men must have been
about 20 to 30 men
i kept i don't know why they left my
high heels on
and i kept kicking them kicking them
with my heels and getting away
i was in the roosevelt hotel i'll never
forget
and i was running from door to door
screaming one time i got down to the
lobby
and in the lobby there were people at
the counter and i kept screaming help me
help me out
and i landed on the floor because i
could barely walk because they had
pulled my legs so far
apart that they they broke the tendons
here in my thighs and my legs were
totally on they didn't work you know
they were mad at me and i woke up again
they chloroformed me a few times and i
woke up again in
like a like a warehouse
and there was a fellow
taking my head and trying to
smash it against the cement floor i
think it was trying to kill me
pretty sure he was and i knew it and um
i don't know if you watch montel
williams but
i watch it a few times in it he
says when if you were in a situation
like that to
talk to your abductor about your name
and your children
and or your family and then that's what
i did i started talking to him about
please don't kill me you know i have
two sons you know and i started
describing my sons and how old they were
at the time and the guy just for a
minute
he let me go it was so scary
i'll never forget because his eyes were
black and then
they changed color to like a normal he
started looking like a normal person
for a minute and he got off me and he
walked over to the door
and he opened it up and i remember i
just
got up and i was running out the door
and i don't know if he snapped back into
killer mode but he was trying to grab
me and thank god you know it was the
middle of the night there weren't many
cars
here in l.a but a a taxi was going down
the street
and um he stopped and picked me up
and i remember a few miles down the road
i told him look you know i've just been
raped and abducted i said i don't i
don't have any money on me
and this bastard he says you know
just get out of my cab i just got all
mad
drew me out of the cabin i remember i
was on the sidewalk
down franklin and i couldn't stand up my
legs weren't working
so i i was scared that the people that
did it to me i
i was scared that they would hurt my
kids
so i didn't go to the authorities
about it you know
so you moved you moved to l.a at some
point i did yeah how old were you when
you moved here
19 19. drug drug started for you at what
age
about 16 but i mean
my whole childhood i'd been given drugs
it was she threw me out when i was 16
because i wasn't no longer useful to her
you know she gambled all the money
away that she made trafficking me
it's weird how in the 70s you know the
people would switch babies like that and
steal
babies from people who were born
from somebody famous it turned out that
my dad
is a famous guitar player i can't i
probably should
can't tell you who but
yeah so pretty much they
will sell people's kids who are
if they can get them you know
who are like government officials or
famous people how is this kind of
abuse in your childhood affected you as
an adult
well i can't stop doing drugs
that's for sure
what's your drug today fentanyl
which started with heroin problem yeah
20 years ago
and then fentanyl you smoke it or inject
it
i muscle it so inject
yeah where do you stay now
i have i bought an rv
you know a really cheap one of course
it's a 73
and it's 20 foot
and i've been traveling
down the from pretty much below san
diego
up through california i go up into the
redwoods
i like to travel the coast to california
yeah
and i go fishing yes i find it serene
yeah i like to be alone a lot
it's not surprising well me and my cat
really
kind of travel around which is not easy
when you're
a drug addict because you have to um
you have to go to some pretty seedy
places because it's not like there's a
dealer that you know
in every city right so you have to like
know where to go like the homeless camps
and that's how i need
like a lot of people homeless people and
things like that
how do you support yourself now
well i mean kobe just happened so there
was edd
i was a cocktail waitress in l.a for
probably 30 years
i've been in six horror movies drove my
movie
as an actress i've been in three
music videos here in l.a and do you do
sex work
to support yourself well i have yeah and
dominatrix work which was pretty
interesting i had a girlfriend that
got me into into that
and um
i was a guy who worships my feet
i try not to do i i don't
very often do penetration
i'm bothered by it i find myself
very sexually bothered by anything
sexual
it's probably because when when i was a
child
what happened to me have you been in
love before
have you been in love before have you
been
in love before in love that's what i
thought you asked
i don't think i have no no i don't know
what that is
i think when i when i
had my sons that's as close as things
i've ever felt to like
real love is then
and what they gave to me because
my life i never had that you know
it was the man ignored me in the
household
he turned out to come out of the closet
as gay
which was crazy and
marilyn the the the woman she hated my
god
she hated me she was very abusive
as far as verbally she would
tell my girlfriends that i grew up with
my
my kid friends and their parents
she would say well i have a friend who's
psychic and
and she said this in front of everybody
she could
and they're saying that you know
laurie what's the name i got i don't use
it but
that laurie here is gonna be a
prostitute when she grows up with what
they told me
and i told i keep trying to tell lori
and i'm like seven years old
12 years old and she's saying right in
front of me saying
i keep telling her if she's going to be
a prostitute that she should do it in
las vegas
because then it's gonna be legal for her
there
i don't know if this made her feel
better you know about what she was doing
to me
but some of my girlfriend's parents were
like they felt really bad
really sorry for me and they would hide
me i got to stay at their house
you know for a while there were parents
who just
were appalled by her behavior
towards me yeah it's kind of a rude
thing to say
a little kid you know tell me about your
children
my sons i have a well i have these 20
now my eldest and my youngest is 17.
did you raise them yes yeah
they live with their dads though i
didn't believe that
it disturbs me that men end up seeing
their kids every two weeks on the
weekends
and uh women are pulling out their hair
trying to raise these kids you know with
the house and alimony and child support
and the pool boy
you know on the couch um it was never
what i wanted
so i told them before i ever even gave
birth
both of their dads i said you know well
you're gonna
raise the kid right i'll give you
custody if you
if you make i can't pay child support
but i'd like to be the one to seize my
kids whenever i can and
whenever i want to because it's just i'm
not the same lifestyle as
most people and they agreed and they're
both
very good dads my my youngest studies
the pommel horse
and my oldest is in college in portland
they're good boys they never touch drugs
they might see this i don't know but if
they do you probably still couldn't
convince them that i do drugs because i
never
i never did in front of them my youngest
got a big argument with her stepmother
about it
she does not i've never seen her do
drugs my mom he was totally sticking up
for me i'm like
but that's important to me not to let
them see it
but they still are hopefully they're
it's rebellion but neither one of them
will touch anything like that
pretty proud of them that's great yeah
i'm lucky
with that dude what do you what do you
think about having a childhood as
traumatic as yours i mean how it
reshapes your adult life
well it's made me the type of person who
would never hurt anybody
you know
i don't know it's made me very sexually
repressed i know that
is that the word repressed so you're
you're more sexual or afraid of
i was more sexual when i was little
which is really strange
i really was very sexually open
when i was little i was very attracted
to men
older men now not so much anymore
no i don't even know i prefer to just be
by
myself at night and read a book to tell
you the truth
me and the cat i don't i mean i had
growing up in my 20s i had quite a few
enjoyable
you know boyfriends and things like that
but now i'm 51
and i don't i prefer to be by myself i
don't expect to
have a relationship or a boyfriend
again ever are you lonely
no no what emotions do you deal with
do you get depressed or do you yeah you
do
but it's empty you know what i mean
like i'm i'm very i study science a lot
and a very scientific mind so when
i have an emotion i study it in myself
and i want to know where
the root comes from but when i get
depressed
like it's sadness
i can't pinpoint it you know what i mean
i can't find it where
it comes from where the roots are you
know
i would like to know you know there was
a time when
i stopped doing drugs and i taught yoga
for a few years
but it i don't know about anybody who
studied yoga but
it's like doing drugs anyway you do it
and then like
an hour later like whoa you know you see
things and stuff
have you experienced love you think
maybe with your sons
yes yeah very much still do they're very
loving
but outside of outside of your children
no
i find that sometimes strangers are even
kinder to me
but sometimes not
i had this this gentleman that
approached me
and wanted to have a drink with me as a
friend
he gave me a lot of money and he never
like tried to touch me that i could tell
for seven years we were friends
sometimes he would stay the night at my
house things like that
when i lost my house he offered to let
me stay with him for a while and stayed
with him for a while
well guess what this was just recently
about a year ago
when i bought the rv i bought it to run
away from this guy
because he was drugging me the whole
time
and he he ended up putting
there are a lot of them left i had some
that were life-threatening surgically
removed their
needles tattoo needles some of them
body piercing needles some of them
intervenous
needle tips long ones and there are over
a hundred
shoved deep inside of my
muscles here on my legs here
on my arms and one or two in the roof of
my mouth here
that she's only taken one out one over
here
next to my neck that they removed
because it was
gonna it was poking into my neck
um i've been kind of waiting for kobit
to be
over to be able to go and just get them
all taken out
you know but it's gonna take a lot of
surgery
you know and i'll be i'll have to be in
the hospital for a long time
and um but
it's very painful they migrate
a lot of them have migrated these
migrated to the surface
yeah i saw those scars on your shoulder
yeah these are all from that
yeah they're from needles under your
skin under
they're shoved deep and the only place
that he could get him
you know because i had i'm very tiny so
the muscle structure here
he had them buried in there but they
came out and in here and they kind of
coming out
here very very painful and here and here
a lot of them in here
i think it's pretty messed up the the
ones in the roof of my mouth that's
pretty cruel
i see like when i look over to the side
there's a light
that goes on and off in my in my in my
eye
it's the same it's like a flash when i
look
over a certain way or my head turns a
certain way it's caused
the the eye to so it
must have hit the eye somehow i don't
know
if you know i've been kind of a little
afraid you know to check out where else
he put them
yeah you seem very down to earth and
well adjusted for someone who's been
through what you've been through
yeah yeah i'm afraid to ask what's the
most important lesson you've learned
in your life
i don't know
i guess i'm really scared people
i am deep down inside i'm terrified of
them that's why i guess i'm such a loner
and i don't trust anybody i mean
the guy who
i woke up at the roosevelt the only
reason i went with him is
because i knew him for seven years he
was my
ex-husband's dealer
dealt in vicodin pills for that seven
years
and i knew him and i never thought that
that he would do something to hurt me
but that really wasn't the case they
they were gonna kill me that night when
i called that guy a few days later
the phone dropped he got just
he was couldn't believe it was me
because he couldn't believe i was alive
a lot of people in the world you know
that are so messed up that nobody wants
to
nobody wants to see that or believe that
it's going on out there but
it does it really does
people to do some pretty messed up
things out there to other people
in my heart i never found that i could
i can't wrap my head around somebody
being like that
but it's going on
so i guess you know
i guess i just i really learned never to
trust anyone i guess that's why i don't
think i've ever loved
because some people will use that and
pretend
like they love you just to get close
enough to hurt you
really bad
all right clover thank you so much for
sharing your story
yeah thanks for listening yes
i wish you a happy summer in your rv
travels
yeah with your cat yeah kujo
it's like mini saint bernard it's a cat
or a dog
a cat but it's not a cat